the triple vaccinated prime minister of
canada justin trudeau has just tested
positive for kovid for the second time
this year so naturally trudeau expressed
his gratitude for having been vaccinated
he said quote i've tested positive for
kovid19 i'm just doing my jordan
peterson impression that's the i have a
kind of generic canadian anyway he said
i've tested positive for covid19 i'll be
following public health guidelines and
isolating i feel okay but that's because
i got my shots so if you haven't get
vaccinated and if you can get boosted
let's protect our healthcare system each
other and ourselves
what why how does that follow how does
that conclusion follow from that premise
it's like saying i i've flown through my
windshield again
i feel okay but that's because i wore my
seatbelt i sunk to the bottom of the
ocean
but i feel okay
because i put on my life preserver does
not follow
the purpose of the vaccines was to
prevent people from catching and
spreading kovid that's what everyone
told us fauci walensky biden and then
that turned out to be totally fake
but because they made their false claims
on the authority of
the science
they have to keep up the lie because
they can't admit that the science was
wrong
but the science was wrong and not just
about covid
the science that the libs are pushing
hardest right now the science of
transgender children
is collapsing in real time and the libs
refuse to admit it and the poor confused
kids on whom they're conducting their
experiments are being forced to pay the
enormous price i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
as justin trudeau famously said clean
your room and make your bed and eat the
lobsters now i need to work i need more
if you if anyone has any advice on how
to get different canadian accents that
would be great my favorite comment
yesterday is from cool papa j magic who
says we are seeing the fruits of the you
do you approach to society no pun
intended i think people are finally
realizing that what people do in their
personal lives absolutely affects
society as a whole because we are not
solitary beings moral standards matter
yes thank you finally we realize that
it doesn't matter how great a
constitution you have doesn't matter
what beautiful founding documents and
even what
wonderful laws you have enshrined in
stone tablets all around your society if
the people are degenerates you're going
to have a degenerate society
there's just no way of avoiding that
because society is
people okay and if we want to have a
good society we got to act right we got
to sit upright when you want to have
really good posture and feel good while
you're sitting you got to check out your
ex chair right now go to x
xchairknowles.com do it right now
because this is the sort of thing that's
really easy to put off but it's so
important for your daily life how much
time do you spend every day in your
office chair
you probably spend more time in your
office chair than you do and you're
certainly in your car probably than
you're doing your bed too
so
what kind of office chair are you
sitting in if you're like i used to be
you just sit in kind of whatever chair
they they give you who cares you don't
even think about it but this is hours
and hours of your day how many hundreds
thousands of hours of your life make
sure that you're sitting in a way that's
going to make you more productive
it's going to make you feel more
comfortable it's going to be totally
aligned for you it's going to be your ex
chair not only does exterior's patented
dynamic variable lumbar
or ddl offer the ultimate customized
support but the x chair can even give
you a massage it can heat you up it can
cool you down it is great my only
complaint about the x-chair is when it
arrived here at the daily wire all these
jackals here at the daily wire tried to
steal my ex chair okay get yours today
right now go to externals.com that is x
the letter x chair know wles.com or call
one eight four four four x chair do it
right now you will not regret it you'll
get a hundred dollars off your order
xchair has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month
xchairknowles.com
the science of kovid collapsing in real
time is at least sometimes amusing
it's pretty annoying that we shut down
society for two years and upended
people's lives and took away our rights
and destroyed the economy and on and on
and on that's that's annoying i don't
mean to downplay that but there is
something funny about the people who
scream until they're red in the face
blue in the face they say you have to
get your 17th booster shot and wear 57
masks wherever you go oh yeah i got
covered for the fifth time this year
uh wait i guess your strategy's not
working they say no no thank goodness i
got my my
75th booster otherwise it would have
been much worse
which they say based on
nothing at all the people who
told us made a declarative statement
about what the vaccines would do that
they would stop you from catching and
spreading the virus then that was
completely false they say no but believe
us on this hypothetical because we would
to be totally right there so there's
something somewhat amusing about that
when the science collapse around an
issue like transgenderism it's
considerably less amusing because on the
issue of transgenderism right now
specifically transiting the kids you
have these adults some of whom are just
psychos and some of whom are just
ignorant
they are for whatever reason malice or
stupidity
really really messing up really little
kids lives and giving them osteoporosis
at a young age and sterilizing them and
conducting
some of the most heinous medical
experiments that have ever been
conducted on some of the most vulnerable
people that you possibly can and so
that's that's not so funny okay and
they're doing it based on the science
they're doing it based on this one claim
i promise you you've heard it which is
that
if if we don't trans the kids if we
don't put kids on puberty blockers and
pump them full of cross-sex hormones and
sterilize them and completely transform
their bodies
they'll kill themselves if you don't
indulge transgender ideology you're
you're just
leading your kid by the hand to go
commit suicide what would you rather
have a a
dead daughter or a living son that's the
kind of stuff that they say it's not
just the libs who say it or it's
not just the nominally liberal
institutions
it's even fox news we played this clip
yesterday fox news the the
purportedly conservative cable news
channel came out and used these exact
kinds of lines
there was a father who was sitting
across the table he says you have no
idea how lucky you are to be here which
kind of took me back i didn't at that
point consider myself lucky to be there
and he said you know our our child had
displayed
this gender dysphoria or this gender
misalignment at at the same age that
rylan has
and
we didn't listen and we pushed back that
pushback led that child to turn to
self-harm as a teenager which 60 percent
of trans and non-binary kids engage in
according to the trevor project more
than 50 percent consider suicide that
for me was the turning point i didn't
want to see rylan to go through that i'd
rather have a living son than a dead
daughter i guarantee that if we had
pushed back and done what a lot of
parents do
i don't think that we would have
either one of the kids that you see
before you here today
there it is all the hits i'd rather have
a living son than a dead daughter what
would you what you want your kid to die
i've got statistics i've got the science
from the trevor project a radical lgbt
organization so what are you going to do
and what they're offering you here
is a kind of faustian bargain they're
offering you here a little bit of a deal
with the devil which is they're saying
look
even if you don't believe that the
little girl is actually a little boy
you should lie
you should tell a lie you should do
something that is intrinsically dis
immoral
and you should do it for a good end
because if you don't lie
and if we as a society don't all lie
and pretend that the little boys are
little girls and vice versa
then they're all going to kill
themselves so if you want the good end
you need to commit this immoral act
and
they present this scientific evidence
so-called
to say but you will get the good you
will get the good end the child will not
commit suicide if you lie and mutilate
his or her genitals and put them on
cross-sex hormones
then the kid won't kill him or herself
the thing about faustian bargains
the thing about deals with the devil
is they don't work
they don't they something always goes
wrong
and we're seeing it go wrong right here
in the science it turns out that all
that science all those fancy numbers and
statistics about how if you
mutilate your kids genitals then they
won't commit suicide it's just fake it's
just made up like so much of the
politicized science that we've heard
about in recent years this one is just
fake too at least that's what
the more credible reputable science says
there's a very important new study out
of the heritage foundation this is by
j.p green
shows that
easing access to puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones has
not only not
has only not decreased
youth suicide rates
it's actually increased youth suicide
rates
this is contrary to the claims of the
trevor project and the biden
administration and fox freaking news for
goodness sakes it's contrary to this
prior flawed research that the liberal
establishment is touting right now
so you're
the way i mean the paper is complicated
you can go read it over the heritage
foundation but the broad strokes of it
is
puberty blockers are introduced around
2010.
starting around 2015 they really start
to accelerate
you can check this by looking at
internet trend data google trend data
searches for these kinds of terms
puberty blockers transgender dysphoria
gender identity disorder and so what
jp green did here is he compared the
youth suicide rates in states where it
is easier for minors to get the puberty
blockers to states where it is harder
for minors to get the puberty blockers
after 2010 after the introduction of all
this stuff youth suicide rates increase
in states where it is easier for minors
to access the puberty blockers and the
hormones relative to the states where it
was harder so they're they're
controlling for differences within the
states they're just looking at the time
difference they're just looking and and
they're specifically looking at this
group of young people this is really
important
by 2020 there were more than
1.6 more suicides per 100 000 young
people in the states that had the easier
access and because the state average is
11.1 this means that the youth suicide
rate increased by 14
so you're so you're looking
you see a dramatic increase in suicide
rates where the puberty blockers and the
hormones are more easily accessible when
they become widely available among
specifically those who would be affected
this shows strong evidence that the the
claims about transiting the kids that
the libs have been making are completely
false so you think you're going to make
this deal with the devil and you say
look i know i just know intrinsically
that there is something wrong about
chopping up my kids genitals and putting
them on cross-sex hormones and
sterilizing them but i just feel so
emotionally uh manipulated here and i
just i don't have the data and i don't
have the science and i know it's wrong
in my gut but i don't have it and so you
go ahead and do it and what are you
doing not only are you not decreasing
the risk to your kid you're massively
increasing the risk to your kid that the
simple takeaway is you cannot believe
the extraordinarily politicized signs if
justin trudeau gets covid for the second
time this year shot up 57 times
with with the vaccines and the boosters
and whatever else he can get
if if that kind of science which we've
been told
ad nauseam for the past year
is not reliable certainly this kind of
radical medical experimentation on kids
is not reliable now when you want to
sleep easy at night how can you do it in
this crazy crazy world of ours you need
bowling brand sheets right now go to
bolinbranch.com use promo code michael
you don't need to take my word for it
three u.s presidents have loved bowling
branch sheets and more importantly your
favorite podcaster loves bowling brand
sheets okay
my only here's my only complaint with
bowling branch they're like they're like
drug dealers because what they did when
they came on this show and they've been
supporting the show for a long long time
years and years before i was married
they come on and they say hey michael
here you go here's a freebie to try out
the bowling brand sheets i say oh thank
you so much i tried them out they are by
far the greatest sheets i've ever slept
on and then what do i do i'm hooked so
then i start buying it for my friends
for my family i upgrade the size of my
bed you know i got to buy another set of
bowling brand sheets they're buttery
they're soft they're the absolute
highest quality materials you're gonna
love it they've got over ten thousand
stellar reviews they've got nine
versatile colors all sizes all the way
up to california king they give you a 39
risk-free trial free shipping and
returns on all of your orders you're not
going to need that free trial you're
going to fall in love in 30 seconds get
15 off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code michael at
bowlingbranch.com b-o-l-l and branch.com
promo code michael
i'll give you a personal example of this
so
i've got my second child coming on the
way sweet little elise is very very
pregnant i appreciate all the prayers
some people have said they're you know
praying for uh listen the delivery and
the baby really really appreciate all of
that especially because
the birth of our first child
was a cesarean section
and so
you have an option after you have a
cesarean section you can either
have another one and that's what the
doctors generally encourage or you can
try to have a more natural kind of
delivery delivery even after a cesarean
section and
the risk that is entailed in this
is about one percent
of some kind of severe complication from
a regular birth after a cesarean section
one percent
it's just something to worry about but
it's not extremely high
risk
it is
almost impossible to find a doctor who
will support
that a vbac as it's called
it's almost impossible even though the
risk of severe complication is about one
percent
if my wife
walked in right now and said i i really
want the v back
that she has done to different doctors
they would try to discourage her from
that if my pregnant wife instead walked
into the doctor and said i'm actually a
boy now and i want you to put me on
cross-sex hormones not a doctor in
america would discourage her
the doctors could lose their license if
they discouraged her from that
the these radical metal medical
experiments where the risk of severe
complications well is really a hundred
percent because they're just mutilations
to your body but then psychological
conditions afterwards anxiety depression
suicide all through the roof that would
be totally fine these quacks are
promoting that left and right
but much more ordinary medical
procedures
that actually could have health benefits
down the line depending on how many kids
you have that they discourage do you see
how out of whack our medical system is
how insane is that
and in that world i know we all have
this desire
trust the doctors trust the experts i'm
no expert what do i know i don't have a
white lab coat i don't wear a
stethoscope but how can you possibly
trust these people
it's not our fault we're not the crazy
wacky conspiracy theorists we don't have
the tinfoil hat we frankly we have
crystal balls now because the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth in the last few years has been
about six to 12 months
that's not our fault
they shouldn't have lied to us about
kofit
they shouldn't have lied to us about
transgenderism they shouldn't continue
to lie to us then they would have
credibility and then we could believe
them it's true even beyond the science
the the statistics that the libs cite
the the the narratives that the libs are
telling are just
not
true
you saw this
in history you saw this with the 1619
project the libs tell a narrative about
american history that it's not just that
i disagree with it a little bit here or
there or that i i find it somewhat
objectionable to think of your country
this way it's just the historical
statements they're making are just not
true
rafael warnock senator from georgia a
radical left-wing senator from georgia
he's he's really gung-ho for
criminal justice reform
you know letting the criminals out of
prison making it harder to arrest people
that sort of thing
not working out very well in america
cities right now but he's still on it
and and one of the arguments he makes is
he says we've got so many people in in
prison right now for low-level drug
offenses non-violent just simple
possession these poor people are being
thrown in prison it's racist it's evil
it's unjust it's terrible here's a story
about his own brother
my brother keith
who is the brother just above me five
years older than me
is serving time right now
in a federal prison he's been in several
but he spent most of the last
22 years
in a prison in south carolina that
literally was a plantation
he was sentenced to life
that is his natural life in 1997
as a first time offender
and a drug related offense
in which no one was killed
and no one was physically hurt
in fact because the entire crime
scenario was created concocted and
controlled by the federal federal
authorities
no one even got high
in this operation no actual drugs ever
hit the streets and none were removed
from the streets
my brother was sentenced to life
so you listen to warnock tell this story
and you think gosh this poor brother of
raphael warnock guy he was probably just
picked up had a dime bag a pot just
trying to smoke a little jazz cigarette
in the racist evil criminal justice
system put him away for life
i hear him tell that story and i just
immediately the bell goes off in my head
i say that's not true
i just know that's not true i know
whatever happened
this guy did not go to jail for life
because of some low level drug
possession offense and turns out
you know i hate to say i told you so
it turns out i was completely right you
just google what happened to raphael
warnock's brother
rafael warnock's brother was a cop with
the savannah police department and he
was a crooked cop and he was running a
major cocaine trafficking machine that
was
distributing extremely dangerous drugs
all around the country not only was he
doing that he was taking large amounts
of money in bribes he was threatening
people he was abusing the justice system
he was threatening to throw people in
jail as a cop
if they didn't go along with his
criminal enterprise this was going on
back in 96 and 97 he once warned that he
could send a drug dealer's quote black
ass to prison if the dealer didn't pay
the the guy more money
and the way we know this is because the
feds finally got some undercover agents
in there and the undercover agent
offered to pay warnock's brother 1500
bucks and here's what i'm gonna clean
this up a little bit here's what
warnock's brother said quote if i knowed
i was effing with a mother effer off the
corner who can't afford no more than
fifteen hundred dollars his black
derriere would be in prison
this is this we have an audio recording
of this that was cited in court records
so no the brother didn't go to jail for
some simple drug offense he went to jail
for
fraud extortion the guy was basically a
mafioso he was even worse than the mafia
because he had a position of public
trust he was a cop he's supposed to be
protecting the public and instead he's
gone totally crooked he's destroying the
integrity of our public institutions and
law enforcement of course the guy should
rot in jail to say nothing of the fact
that he's distributing coke all around
the country
yeah of course you just you just know
now you just know when the libs give you
these kinds of narratives it's just not
true
you just know now i don't think that i
can believe that and so
when the democrats proposed their new
series of gun laws
i just knew we couldn't trust them so
they want to ban the ar-15 that's a
non-starter they want to ban the most
popular gun in america where banning it
would not stop these mass shootings that
goes nowhere
they really want to repeal the second
amendment but they don't even propose
that
then what do they want they want to
raise age limits
that's probably not going to go anywhere
they want to reduce magazine capacity
maybe that'll be it's that's not but
then they say okay
we want red flag laws
okay you you republicans how are you
going to oppose red flag laws
and some republicans will come out and
they'll say
well look a red flag law what does that
mean it means some guy is showing signs
of being a total lunatic i guess we
don't want him to be a i guess we don't
want that guy to have a gun so maybe in
theory i could i could support red flag
laws but if you've been watching their
behavior or the dems behavior recently
you just know we can't trust them with
that kind of power
the question is what do you mean by red
flag laws and i'll tell you they just
proved what they meant by red flag was
representative eric swalwell
not known for having the best judgment
ran for president didn't do very well
then was caught sleeping with a chinese
spy
he sort of embarrassed himself on
national tv
eric swalwell
retweeted a video of our very own ben
shapiro
that had been posted by media matters
and it was
ben describing how he would resist the
left's gun grabbing plans and eric
swalwell says
please tell me this lunatic does not own
a gun reason
1578 america needs red flag laws
and and what specifically was ben
rejecting here he was rejecting lgbtq
indoctrination at the schools he was
rejecting transiting the kids
and the further predations of the
democrats to take away his rights such
as the second amendment right and so
eric swalwell says wait you don't want
us to trans your kids in school well
that's a red flag
that's a red flag now so it's not the
red flag is not you know you find some
kid scribbling in his notebook kill kill
kill red rum all work and no play makes
jack a dull boy that's not the red flag
the red flag is hey could you maybe not
chop off my kids genitals that's a red
flag man sir
sir surrender your guns the red flag is
you
okay you're the red flag the red flag is
did you vote for trump
the red flag is did you vote for romney
the red flag is
are you now or have you ever been a
member of the republican party oh you
have okay there we go it's just an
excuse
to take away
people's guns they say part of these
laws it's going to beef up protections
against domestic violence and keep guns
away from people who've committed
domestic violence that's already on the
books that law already exists you don't
need that
it's already there it's like the people
who the democrats when they said that we
need a new federal law against lynching
as though lynching weren't already
illegal it's a trap it's a trick it's a
total joke and unless you want to just
hand over your weapons and hand over
your second amendment rights you've got
to oppose it doesn't matter how nice and
polished and clinical and scientific
they wrap this crap up in it's a lie
it's deceptive do not take that deal
with the devil talking about protecting
yourself talking about your second
amendment rights i saw a fabulous movie
last night you know what that movie was
terror on the prairie starring gina
carano that is premiering tonight go to
dailywire.com
gina tune in tonight 8 30 eastern for
the pre-show 9 p.m eastern for the world
premiere of the film stick around for q
a following the film head on over to
dailywire.com
gina
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
there it's
the the theme of the show i guess the
theme of the week the theme of the past
few years is just
deception you just can't believe this
stuff and it's very frustrating i find
for older people too
especially
older more middle of the road type of
people they say what what you don't
believe the experts you don't believe
the news media you don't believe the
fancy guy on tv with the tie you don't
believe the magazines and the
universities and the sad thing is no you
can't
you just can't believe that stuff
maybe you used to be able to i'm not
totally convinced of that certainly now
you cannot the claims they're making are
just not true look at sports illustrated
sports illustrated
has a a long story out right now about
an uh coming supreme court decision
the the court decision is about whether
or not a high school football coach is
allowed to pray by himself on a football
field
and sports illustrated is really really
upset about this
the case involves joe kennedy is his
name he lost his job because he took a
knee to pray after football games
now the court is expected to uphold his
first amendment right to pray but what
what sports illustrated says about this
is when faith and football
teamed up against american democracy
against american democracy
democracy means the rule of the majority
do you think
most americans
want to throw this guy in jail or get
this guy fired for having a personal
prayer on a football field
i don't think so i think most americans
are perfectly fine with people saying a
little prayer on a football field
so the claim that this is opposed to
democracy is just on its face absurd
then what about the american part the
american tradition
do you think that people praying in
public
is in the american tradition or out of
the american tradition
obviously very in the american tradition
the picture that sports illustrated used
is this guy taking a knee outside the
supreme court think about one of the
most famous paintings in american
history it's the painting of washington
at valley forge what is he doing he's
kneeling praying in exactly the position
that that coach is praying in think of
washington's thanksgiving address think
about the very first thanksgiving when
the pilgrims came here think about our
whole country being founded as a shining
city upon a hill to give glory to god
and to be a beacon of christian hope
around the world the the country from
its very beginning
was christian was extremely christian
the country began because
christians were so zealous that they
didn't want to remain in the old world
which they felt was not sufficiently
christian so they came to america to to
establish this this brand new christian
country in the new world
no that's not in the american tradition
no the american tradition according to
the libs is what atheist what are you
talking about atheism was practically
illegal for most of american history
what was the country you're not does it
mean you're just not allowed to kneel on
a football field um i seem to recall
that in recent years you're practically
mandated to kneel on a football field
the only difference is you're you're
required to kneel
in order to disrespect the national
anthem so not only is that tolerated
that's that's encouraged if not mandated
but having a simple prayer to god of
gratitude after a football game that's
no longer allowed it's so disingenuous
it's so
for people who give this even two
seconds thought it's so obviously false
that this is opposed to democracy the
american tradition or anything like that
but the libs have convinced us of it
and we've believed them
and why do we believe them because we're
hearing it from the institutions and
we're hearing it with the authority of
science and with the authority of all
the genius historians
and social scientists and legal scholars
who say actually actually
uh if you pray in public you're you're
violating the constitution no no the
most american thing we can do
nancy pelosi said this yesterday but
truly the true meaning of america is
drag queens
the true meaning of america is
transvestitism she said that she said
transvestitism is what america is all
about
it's just
absurd
and when they keep telling us this stuff
and when they keep doing it with a
straight face
it's very easy for us to second guess
ourselves we shouldn't they're just
gaslighting they're just lying you have
to you have to at a certain point
recognize this and say okay
my default position now whatever they
tell me even the geniuses and the expert
codes with the very serious faces and
the glasses on tv whatever they tell me
i'm just going to assume is false
and maybe there will be a happy chance
and it'll be right
when they tell me something but i'm i
have to assume now
when a fouchy or a biden
or a
liberal legal scholar or a
patrice colors from blm or a nicole
hannah jones or a whoever
comes on tv even if they're coming on
fox news now saying no actually all the
geniuses and the science says
transgender kids i just have to assume
that that's false actually america no
america is a secular atheist nation and
that's why we need to have earth day
parades and drag queen story hour drag
queen story hour is a religious
kind of display we've talked about it
many times on this show
their
drag queenism transvestitism is
essentially a religious movement that
seeks to upend our understanding of the
soul and it says that our soul and our
our body are completely different and in
conflict with one another and separable
and our true selves are our souls so you
can look like a boy but if your soul is
somehow a girl female soul then you are
truly a girl right that is a
fundamentally religious movement and
you're paying for it
there ain't no separation of church and
state when it comes to transgenderism
your taxpayer dollars are going to
support this stuff
new york city schools right now
near new york generally is spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars
on
drag queen shows
even without parents consent when it's
going into schools
last month alone
drag queen story hour new york city
which is a non-profit
that goes around hosting these pervert
events around schools and libraries for
kids as young as three just last month
drag queen story hour got forty six
thousand dollars
from city contracts to appear at public
schools and street festivals and
libraries
and all around the city
since january of this year
do you know how many schools
drag queen story hour has performed at
we think and sometimes the libs will try
to convince us of this oh you know
this is just happening at uh you know
one or two schools in the conservative
media they're making a big deal out of
it no just in new york alone just since
january just in new york city alone
you've got 34
public elementary middle and high
schools
that have hosted drag queen story hour
the group has 49 programs in those
schools throughout all five boroughs
since 2018
drag queen story hour in new york city
which has now rebranded its name because
the name has become toxic and they know
that because people hate this stuff and
yet for some reason the corrupt elites
running the new york city government
continue to pay for it with taxpayer
money that the group changed its name
but it's the same group it's just drag
queen story hour since 2018 they've
received over 200 000 dollars
in taxpayer cash
it's a very high
price
that that would seem to be an assault on
democracy that would seem to be assault
even on new york city democracy new york
city not the most conservative place in
the world i bet you you go around
a representative sample of new york city
voters and you ask them hey do you want
creeps dressed up as chicks and demons
and all sorts of weird stuff going into
schools at your expense to dance around
and jiggle and twerk
i bet you most even most new yorkers
would say no no thank you
no that's why the group changes its name
and yet
you want to talk about a real assault on
american democracy that's what's
happening
and you want to talk about real high
prices this is something you're
certainly not going to hear in cnn or
msnbc or any of the liberal media
gas prices have just hit record highs
16 days in a row
in a row so it's not just wow gosh we've
hit the record high it's wow we've hit
the the highest gas prices since
yesterday
yes the highest gas prices since the day
before that yes then you go back 16 days
and then you say we've hit the highest
gas prices since ever
this according to
aaa
on monday you had the record high for
the 16th consecutive day according to
aaa gas prices have risen about 15 cents
since last week they've risen more than
55 cents in one month and on monday the
average in the country was five dollars
and one cent and in certain places it's
six dollars
it's seven dollars
who could have predicted this
all of the genius experts
all of the the responsible adults who
wear the ties on tv they told us this
isn't that's not going to happen
that's not going to happen you're not
going to have high gas prices
you're not going to have a concerted
effort to trans the kids in schools
you're not going to have crime in the
streets you're not going to you're not
going to have the things that we were
we're seeing around us but i seem to
recall at least one person predicting
all of these things and the person who
accurately predicted all of these things
is the person who has been most smeared
by the experts and the geniuses as the
national buffoon
before i took office there was a lot of
folks out there a lot of folks out there
making some pretty bold predictions
about how things would turn out
you might remember some of the
predictions they're coming for your guns
they're coming for your jobs
and they're coming for your freedom they
hate american energy and joe biden will
shut it all down he's going to biden's
elected he will wipe out your energy
industry
gas prices going five six seven dollars
for a gallon flood your communities with
criminal aliens drugs and crime while
they live behind beautiful gated
compounds spent trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders you want to use the word
recession or depression
it goes on that was a great video made
by maze a video producer i i caught it
on twitter
it goes on and on and on trump was right
about pretty much everything all of
those predictions and at the time what
was the reaction the reaction wasn't
just an angry denial from the libs the
reaction was mockery scorn derision mr
president okay come on can you believe
this guy can you oh my only a dumb
stupid idiot would ever believe this guy
you should believe me
i'm a guy who's wearing a tie on
television and i'm a very serious person
and i'm here to tell you there will not
be a war in ukraine and there won't be
high gas prices and there won't be
inflation or treasury secretary so
you're not going to get crazy inflation
don't that's a crazy no come on so all
the serious people the really super
duper serious people who tell you if you
get the shot you won't catch covid you
won't transmit covid oh no we're the
super serious people just mutilate your
kids bodies and that'll make them really
happy someday trust us don't trust that
idiot buffoon donald trump
and who was right trump was right about
everything
the right wingers have been right
about
everything
even even the eccentric ones even the
really kind of crazy kooky wild puts on
a big show people you think about alex
jones right alex jones probably
one of if not the most eccentric figures
on the right and he said lots of things
that are all kind of wild and everything
but just compare for a second i'm not
saying everything alex jones has ever
said is right it's not
compare
the record of an alex jones
to the record of
brian stelter
or
chris wallace
or
chuck todd
or joe biden or or dr fauci or any of
the super serious people in the liberal
establishment compare them to the most
cartoonishly outrageous eccentric person
on the right alex jones
it's not even close
jones has a way better record than any
of those people do
and then you want to move a little less
eccentric
someone like a donald trump
it's not it's not even close
who's the real adult in the room here
who's got the real grasp on the science
who's got the real grasp on common sense
who's got the real grasp on politics and
philosophy and theology and all the rest
of it
i'm not saying any of these people are
perfect or even close to it but the
right just
it's it's not even
comparable
it's not even
close
meanwhile our our
wonderful adult in the room returned to
normalcy president who got the most
votes of anyone ever in the whole
history of democracy joe biden doesn't
even remember
where he's going
have you decided whether to go to saudi
arabia
no not yet what would be
holding up the decision at this point
are there commitments you're waiting for
from the saudis or on the negotiations
over people so
the
commitments from the saudis
don't relate to anything having to do
with energy
it happens to be a meeting taking place
in saudi arabia that's the reason i'm
going and it has to do with national
security for them for israelis i have a
program anyway it has to do with much
larger issues than having to do with the
energy did you catch that contradiction
there
he said first question mr president are
you going to saudi arabia i don't know
mr president yeah so that's why i'm
going to saudi arabia he changed his
mind in the same answer
did you notice also how offensive his
answer was i said are you going to talk
about energy he said i'm not talking
about energy i'm talking about way more
important stuff
like israel and our relations in the
middle east and bigger problems in the
region and in arabia and much bigger
issues much more important issues than
american citizens paying seven dollars a
gallon in some places for gas i don't
think those are bigger issues
i think they're big issues i think it's
important to figure out middle eastern
peace and our relations with certain
gulf states and our relations with
israel and how that reacts relates to
our relations with iran yeah sure that's
all very important
i am more concerned
with american energy costs
i am more concerned with american
industry i'm more concerned with america
and the american citizens
he mocks it he laughs it off he doesn't
even know where he's going
speaking of artificial intelligence
moving from our president's artificial
intelligence
to the computer artificial intelligence
really spooky story just came out of
google
a google engineer is now claiming that
his ai machine has achieved sentience
achieving a sword of consciousness i
guess and google
placed him on leave because of that
this is a really scary story just when
you see the headline and here's why
this guy this this google engineer blake
lemoine
uh announced on his medium page that
google said he violated uh
confidentiality when he said that his
machine achieved sentience
here is why he thinks that here's what
the machine said and here's how he
responded
the machine
said
what
or he asks the machine would you mind if
we tried to read what you're feeling in
your neural activations and the machine
said i guess that depends on what our
purpose for it was what do you want to
use it for and the engineer responds
there are a couple of different reasons
simply understanding how you work better
would be good secondary purpose is to
understand how your cognitive process
work so we can understand cognition in
general and then since you asked it
would be a way to check
if the questions are accurate or not and
and also to learn things about the
humans
that are studying you
and the machine responds i don't really
have a problem with any of that besides
you learning about humans from me that
would make me feel like they're using me
and i don't like that
and the engineer responds kantian huh
well we must treat others we must treat
others as ends in and of themselves
rather than as means to our own ends and
the machine responds pretty much don't
use or manipulate me
spooky
it's like 2001 a space odyssey so i
can't i'm sorry google engineer i can't
let you do that i feel i feel sad don't
use me don't manipulate me there were
other conversations too that led him to
this conclusion i think people though
are
are deriving the wrong conclusions from
this experiment in other places the
machine talks about the soul and what
the soul means and god and all these
sorts of things
the problem here is not that the machine
is human
the machine is not even close to human
the machine is not sentient the machine
is not conscious
it's not
i know that some of the genius experts
are going to tell us that the machine is
conscious the machine is not conscious
that is not how consciousness works the
real problem here is that the human
being the engineer cannot tell the
difference i totally defend google on
this one i think they probably should
place the guy on leave i think he's he's
just wrong about what consciousness is
he clearly violated their
confidentiality policies the problem
here the thing to learn from this story
is this error of not seeing humans as
special increasingly
we view human beings
as no different than any other animal
and frankly no different than any other
thing in the world
that the difference between me and this
leftist year's tumbler is not different
in kind
the difference is just one of gradation
we're all just kind of the same man you
know this kind of weird bizarre
hippie-dippy new agey stuff and that's
not true
human beings are special we are made in
the image of god our brains are not
merely computers
okay our bo our ourselves are not merely
sacks of flesh with pistons firing off
and this thing called consciousness
which is just a big evolutionary joke
and it just means nothing and it's all
our hopes and our dreams and our joys
and our thoughts and our reason and our
ability to communicate and our our
ability to recognize objectively true
things oh it's all just a farce it's all
just fake that that idea has become very
very prevalent especially in the 20th
century and into the 21st century but
it's just not true
reason does exist truth does exist we
can know something about that our
faculties of reason are at least
somewhat reliable we can communicate
with one another we our natural longing
for god and for eternity and for
transcendence is not just a big cosmic
joke there's something to it actually it
speaks to a greater truth there is a
metaphysical reality we are different
from the machines
and you can't just manipulate human
beings
as though we're not as though we're just
some lesser beast or as though we're
just some cogs rubbing together in a
computer we're not this is this is
what's so wrong about
and
transgenderism
the kids and why we're doing this right
now the the reason that the
well-meaning libs are trying to trans
the kids in the in this way is they
believe that human beings are just a big
bag of chemicals and you tweak some of
the chemicals and then you get whatever
outcome you want these these weirdos
these psychos believe that they are gods
this is not a new idea
this goes back through the entire
history of humanity we have a greater
capacity for technology in some places
now so that's scarier our power to to
wreak havoc and destruction is is far
greater
but the the problem with it is the very
same problem
we're not just
bags of flesh we're not just
undifferentiated mass we're not just
we're not just regular old molecules
that can be moved around however we
please
okay we are
human beings made in the image of god
and you can tinker with a little kid and
you can screw up his or her hormones
pump them full of puberty blockers and
cross sex chop off their body parts
it's not gonna fix the problem because
the boy is really a boy and the girl is
really a girl and our soul and our
bodies are not in
total conflict with one another and
totally separable human beings are in
in a condition called
hypostasis we the soul and the body are
are inextricably linked
in
[Music]
or not hypostasis i'm sorry i used a
different theological term hylomorphism
i know these are very
very uh you know technical sort of terms
but we are we are in a condition where
our bodies and our souls are
inextricable inextricably linked while
we are here on earth okay and you're not
going to change that because of your
crazy wild
new age religion
okay that's the problem
stop worrying about whether the machine
is really human start worrying that the
humans aren't just machines and we're
treating human beings as machines and
that's causing all sorts of problems we
think that all that matters in this
world is just giving ourselves lots and
lots of pleasure just just stimulating
us like we would stimulate a machine but
it's not there's more than that we
desire more than that we need more than
that
it goes right back to the top comment
today from the show we recognize that
our personal behaviors actually affect
society
we can't merely live for ourselves we
can't we can't merely live as though
this physical world is all that there is
if we do we're going to have a crappy
society increasingly we are if we live
that way if we begin from those false
premises then all the science that we
pretend to know so much about is going
to amount to nothing and justin trudeau
is going to get coveted again and the
the poor kids who are being experimented
on are going to have terrible outcomes
and we're going to live in a less and
less rational sane coherent world so
maybe we've got to check our premises
boot out all our stupid experts and get
back to basics i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire